Transcriber: Marah Albakkawi
المدقّق: mohannad derane
سـيـداتي آنســاتـي سـادتــي
جئت لكم في مكاني هذا،
أحدثُكم من موقعي هذا
على هذه المنصة العالمية
حيث أقول لكم كلمتي هذه،
وآمل أن أكون ضيفًا خفيفًا عليكم
أعلم أن هناك منكم من يتساءل ويقول:
“لما يتحدث هذا الفتى باللغة العربية؟”
لا ألومك يا صديقي فأنا من أخطأت من البداية
أنا لم أقدم نفسي لكم
أنا فارس ياسر عثمان
مقدم محتوى باللغة العربية الفصحى
حسناً، أعلمُ أنّ هناك من يتساءل أيضاً
ويقول:
“ولما اللغة العربية تحديداً؟”
“لما اللغة العربية التي أصر عليها، ويقوم
بالتحدث بهذه الطريقة”
حسناً يا صديقي أنا شخصياً عندما بدأت
بتقديم المحتوى باللغة العربية،
لم أحظ بالاهتمام الكافي،
فهناك الكثير و الكثير من الأشخاص
لا يهتمون باللغة العربية
حتى لم أحصل على الدعم الكافي من أي شخص،
ولكن قلت: لماذا لا أقوم بتوظيف اللغة
العربية
بطريقة تعجب الناس؟
فحاولت وحاولت وعاودت الكرة
وحاولت وحاولت أيضاً وفشلت وحاولت أيضاً،
حتى وصلت إلى الطريقة التي تعجب بها الناس
حتى يعجب الناس بطريقة اللغة العربية التي
أتحدث بها
حسناً
وتخيلت لوهلةٍ
أن لو كان كل الأشخاص
يتحدثون باللغة العربية
شيءٌ غريبٌ، أليس كذلك؟
أعلم أن هناك شخصٌ سيظهر في المنتصف،
ويتحدث بلغة أخرى يدمجها مع اللغة العربية
أجل، فالتحضر هنا
المتحضر هو من يدمج اللغة العربية
المتحضر هو من يدمج كلماتٍ من لغات أخرى
كالإنجليزية أو الفرنسية وغيرها الكثير
من اللغات في وسط اللغة العربية
بينما الرجعي هو من يتحدث لغة عربية كاملة
حسناً، لو كان كل البشر يتحدثون لغة عربية
وظهر شخص في المنتصف...
يتحدث بالإنجليزية مخلوطة بالعربية،
سأنظر له...
بصدمة
حتى تحترق النجوم
وتفنى العوالم،
حتي تتصادم الكواكب،
حتى ينطفئ القمر، حتى تجف الأنهار والبحار
والمحيطات،
حتى يعجز لساني عن الكلام
وأنظر له وأقول: “بحقك يا فتى!”
“لماذا تتحدث بهذه الطريقة؟ فقط تحدث باللغة
العربية بدون دمج أي كلمات من لغة أخرى.”
فيقل لي ويقول: “لماذا تجادل معي يا فتى؟
أريد أن أتحدث بأي طريقة أريدها.”
أنا فقط هكذا ان انجلش
فأنظر له وقلت ان انجلش
يا أهلاً وسهلاً يا فتى.
(تصفيق)
أمزح يا أصدقاء
عندما يقول لي أنا فتىً دوش
فقط اهدأ وركز وقل له:
روتانا!! روتانا بأي شكل من الأشكال يا فتى
فقط أمزح ليس هنالك أي قصدٍ أو أي مسخفة
حسناً،
لا أطلب منك التحدث باللغة العربية
في كل مكان وزمان،
أطلب منك فقط
مراعاة أن هذه اللغة يجب أن تهتم بها،
يجب أن تصطفيها في كل وقت وفي كل حين
وأوضح لك كل ما في لغتك العربية
وعذرًا يا صديقي
من يتحدث بمعظم الكلمات
بلغة أخرى، ويدمجها في وسط اللغة العربية،
آسف على اللفظ فهو شخص بلا هوية
لا أقول لك ألا تتعلم لغة أخرى
يجب أن تتعلم العديد والعديد من اللغات
فمن تعلم لغة قوم أمن مكرهم، صحيح؟
لذلك هذه هي اللغة الأم، هذه هي اللغة
التي يجب...
هذه هي اللغة التي
يجب أن تفخر بها دائماً وأبداً
افخر بلغتك يا صديقي، سلمت يداك